>> Laura: ONE FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR ANDY McCABE ADMITTED
ON "60 MINUTES" LAST NIGHT
SHOULD ALARM ALL OF YOU.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW WHEN I WOULD BE
OUT OF A JOB, SO I JUST PUT MY
HEAD DOWN AND GOT TO WORK TRYING
TO STABILIZE THE PEOPLE AROUND
ME AND DO THE THINGS THAT I FELT
WE NEEDED TO DO WITH THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, GETTING CASES
OPEN, AND GETTING A SPECIAL
COUNSEL APPOINTED.
>> IS THERE AN INAPPROPRIATE
RELATIONSHIP, A CONNECTION
BETWEEN THIS PRESIDENT AND OUR
MOST FEARSOME ENEMY, THE
GOVERNMENT OF RUSSIA?
>> ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS IN LEAGUE WITH THE
RUSSIANS?
>> I'M SAYING THAT THE FBI HAD
REASON TO INVESTIGATE THAT.
WE TALKED ABOUT WHY THE
PRESIDENT HAD INSISTED ON FIRING
THE DIRECTOR AND WHETHER OR NOT
HE WAS THINKING ABOUT THE RUSH
INVESTIGATION, AND DID THAT
IMPACT HIS DECISION?
IN THE CONTEXT OF THAT
CONVERSATION, THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL OFFERED TO WEAR
A WIRE INTO THE WHITE HOUSE.
NOW, HE WAS NOT JOKING.
HE WAS ABSOLUTELY SERIOUS.
THE DISCUSSION OF THE 25TH
AMENDMENT WAS SIMPLY ROD RAISED
THE ISSUE AND DISCUSSED IT WITH
ME IN THE CONTEXT OF THINKING
ABOUT HOW MANY OTHER CABINET
OFFICIALS MIGHT SUPPORT SUCH AN
EFFORT.
>> Laura: OKAY, JUST TO SUM UP
WHAT HE JUST COPPED TO COME OF
THE NEWLY PROMOTED McCABE, OUT
OF POLITICAL DISDAIN, TOOK UPON
HIMSELF TO BE THE ULTIMATE
RESISTANCE HERO.
HE'S SETTING IN MOTION A COUNTER
INTEL INVESTIGATION AGAINST A
SITTING PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, PUSHED FOR A
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND OPENLY
DISCUSSED REMOVING DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT, COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF,
FROM OFFICE.
FOLKS ON THE OTHER NETWORKS ARE
CALLING THIS GUY PATRIOT?
WHAT DO FORMER HIGH-RANKING FBI
OFFICIALS THINK ABOUT ALL THIS
QUESTION RIGHT LET'S DISCUSS
WITH A COUPLE GRADES.
KEVIN BROCK WAS A FORMER FBI
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR INTEL AND
TERRY TURCHIE WAS A FORMER
DEPUTY ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
COUNTERTERRORISM IN THE
COUNTERTERROR DIVISION.
KEVIN, YOU RECENTLY PENNED A
PIECE CALLING McCABE'S
REEMERGENCE NURSING.
>> IT'S A HUGE EMBARRASSMENT AND
I THINK TERRY WILL AGREE THAT
FOR FORMER FBI AGENTS, CURRENT
FBI AGENTS.
WHAT ANDREW MCCABE IS DOING WHAT
HE DID LAST NIGHT FURTHER MISLED
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND ACTUALLY
MANIPULATED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BECAUSE NOW SUDDENLY HE'S A
VICTIM.
AFTER PERPETRATING, ALONG WITH
JIM COMEY, SEVERE DAMAGE TO THE
FBI BECAUSE OF THEIR NOW WHAT WE
KNOW CLEAR BIASES, HE IS GOING
ON A BOOK TOUR TO SELL BOOKS.
>> Laura: EVERYONE IS SELLING
BOOKS.
ALL OF FORMER FBI GUYS ARE
PUSHING THEIR BOOKS.
GOT TO MAKE MONEY.
>> IT'S AMAZING TO US.
HE IS TRYING TO REHABILITATE
HIMSELF WITH THE DAMAGE IS DONE
AND TO DO MORE DAMAGE.
HE HAS CLAIMED, AS YOU JUST
POINTED OUT, WHEN HE BECAME
ACTING DIRECTOR, HE WENT ON A
BINGE OF OPENING CASES AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
ON THE "60 MINUTES" INTERVIEW
LAST NIGHT, HE WAS DECEPTIVE AND
MISLEADING --
>> Laura: HOW SO?
>> HE STATED THAT HE HAD CLEAR
AND ARTICULABLE FACTS FOR
OPENING UP IN FBI --
>> Laura: WHAT WERE THE FACTS?
I'M STILL WAITING FOR THE FACTS.
>> HE SAID THE PRESIDENT
CRITICIZED OUR INVESTIGATION,
THAT WAS NUMBER ONE.
NOT A REASON FOR OPENING UP A
CASE.
HE SAID THE PRESIDENT DIRECTED
JAMES COMEY TO LET MICHAEL FLYNN
OFF THE HOOK.
NO, HE DIDN'T.
IF YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT JAMES
COMEY'S NOTES, HE DIDN'T SAY
THAT.
HE SAID THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN'S
PRESCIENT BUT THE RUSH
INVESTIGATION --
THERE WAS ALL THESE THINGS THAT
DON'T RISE THE LEVEL OF OPENING
UP LEGITIMATE --
>> Laura: HE LOOKED REALLY
EARNEST.
HE LOOKED REALLY EARNEST.
MALCOLM NANCE WAS ON MSNBC,
FORMER COUNTERTERROR SPECIALIST,
AND THIS IS HOW HE DESCRIBES
McCABE LAST NIGHT.
>> THESE PHRASES, TAKING DOWN AN
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
BUREAUCRATIC COUP.
THIS IS DONALD TRUMP'S
CHARACTERIZATION OF WHAT THE
PATRIOTS AT THE FBI AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WHO WERE
DEFENDING THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES --
>> Laura: TERRY, THAT'S ALL HE
WAS DOING, DEFENDING THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> YEAH, HE SURE WAS.
I WILL TELL YOU, I COULDN'T
AGREE MORE WITH WHAT KEVIN JUST
SAID TO YOU.
I CAN'T EVEN WATCH THIS TONIGHT
WITHOUT MY BLOOD BOILING.
I WILL MAKE THREE POINTS.
NUMBER ONE, AS KEVIN WELL KNOWS,
AS ALL OF US WORKED IN THE FBI
THOSE DIVISIONS KNOW, WHAT HE
ESSENTIALLY TOLD US LAST NIGHT'S
AFTER HAVING UNVERIFIED
INFORMATION FOR A YEAR IN THE
FORM OF THE CHRISTOPHER STEELE
DOSSIER, AND THEN GOING TO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND BEING ANGRY
BECAUSE FORMER DIRECTOR COMEY
HAD BEEN FIRED AND NOT LIKING
THE PRESIDENT'S DEMEANOR AND THE
WAY HE DELIVERED WORDS, HE
DECIDED TO GO BACK AND SAY THE
MAN WAS A GREAT THREAT TO
AMERICA.
THAT'S ABOUT WHAT WE GOT LAST
NIGHT AND THAT'S ABOUT WHAT THE
FBI HAD.
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
IT'S EGREGIOUS.
I NEVER THOUGHT IN MY LIFETIME I
WOULD SEE THIS.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT HE OPENED
THE CASE IN MAY OF 2017.
WE HAD JUST COME OFF BY A COUPLE
MONTHS, MARCH, APRIL, GOING BACK
TO DO JANUARY OF 2017, GUESS
WHAT HAD HAPPENED?
WHERE THE OUTGOING OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION UNMASKING PEOPLE
IN THE TRUMP TRANSITION TEAM.
DON'T TELL ME THAT THE COLLUSION
IS NOW STARTING TO COME TOGETHER
AND IT'S NOT ALL POINTING TO THE
PRESIDENT AND RUSSIA.
IT'S POINTING DIRECTLY AT
POLITICS IN THE TOP LAYER OF THE
FBI.
KEVIN KNOWS AND I KNOW AND
ANYONE WHO'S BEEN IN THOSE SPOTS
UP THERE ON THE SEVENTH FLOOR
KNOWS THAT THE FBI AGENTS WHO
WORK IN THE TOP POSITIONS WERE
NOT FOLLOWING THE RULES, THE
GUIDELINES ARE ALL THE POLICIES
PUT TOGETHER FOR DECADES TO
PROTECT.
>> Laura: FOR BOTH OF YOU,
WHAT KIND OF FBI ACTING DIRECTOR
CONVENES OR TAKES PART IN A
MEETING ABOUT THE 25TH AMENDMENT
AND REMOVING THE PRESIDENT?
IS THAT PART OF WHAT AN ACTING
FAI DIRECTOR'S RESPONSIBILITY
IS, TO PRONOUNCE OVER
MEETINGS OR TO TAKE PART IN
THEM?
>> HE SHOULD HAVE IMMEDIATELY
GOT UP AND EXCUSE HIMSELF FROM
THAT MEETING AND SAID I WILL NOT
BE PART OF THIS DISCUSSION.
FIRST OF ALL, THE FBI HAS NO
JURISDICTIONAL ENTRIES OR
ABILITIES IN THE 25TH AMENDMENT
DISCUSSION SO HE SHOULD
HAVE IMMEDIATELY RECOGNIZED HE
HAD NO ROLE AND SHOULD NOT
ABANDON THE MEETING.
>> Laura: TERRY, BILL BARR
JUST SWORN IN LAST WEEK IS THE
NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES.
FORMER AND NOW CURRENT.
HOW DOES HE PROCEED HERE?
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE ENTIRE FBI
HAS TO BE DISMANTLED AND KIND OF
REBORN.
TO RESTORE ITS INTEGRITY.
A LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE DO WORK
THERE BUT IT IS SO TAINTED NOW.
THIS WHOLE INVESTIGATION WITH
THE FROG FROM THE OUTSET AND
IT'S PATENTLY OBVIOUS THAT
ANYONE WILL TAKE OFF THEIR
POLITICAL PARTISAN CAP AND JUST
LOOK AT THE FACTS AND I THINK
ANDREW MCCABE GAVE IT AWAY LAST
NIGHT.
HE GAVE IT AWAY.
I THOUGHT IT WAS SO OBVIOUS THEY
HAD NOTHING OF TRUMP.
>> EXACTLY.
I THINK THE BIG PROBLEM
CONFRONTING THE NEW INTERNALLY
GENERAL AS THIS.
PEOPLE MAY NOT WANT TO GET INTO
THIS DISCUSSION.
AS WE HAVE A POLITICAL PARTY,
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TURNING
HARDER AND HARDER LEFT WHICH IN
ITSELF IS A MAJOR NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK, WE ALSO DO NOT
KNOW EXACTLY TO THIS DAY EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE FBI,
WHETHER THERE STILL EXISTS
WITHIN THE FBI THESE KINDS OF
ISSUES.
PERHAPS PEOPLE APPOINTED BY
McCABE BEFORE HE LEFT.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
ALL THESE THINGS THAT ARE STILL
OUT THERE IN THE UNIVERSE AND
ALL THESE -- PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW
WHO ORCHESTRATED ALL THIS
BECAUSE IT'S ABSOLUTELY JUST
UNBELIEVABLE THAT THERE IS NOT
SOMEBODY BEHIND ALL OF THIS THAT
PULLED IT TOGETHER AND
COMPROMISED THE FBI.
WE ARE NOT GETTING INTO THE FACT
THAT WE COULD'VE HAD -- WE
COULD'VE HAD ANYTHING FROM
BRIBES TO AGREED TO EGO.
ALL THESE THINGS, ALL THESE
THINGS ARE FACTORS.
KEVIN AND I NEVER SAW IN THE FBI
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
IN FACT, WE ALWAYS PRIDED
OURSELVES, AS WE LEFT, PASS
ALONG THE FBI WE FOUND A LITTLE
BIT BETTER TO THE NEXT
GENERATION.
THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN THIS TIME.
>> Laura: ROSENSTEIN IS OUT.
OSUNDAIRO HAS A NEW DEPUTY.
FORMER PARTNER.
IS IT TIME TO FINALLY -- YOU
NEED REPERCUSSIONS FOR BAD
BEHAVIOR.
WILL THERE BE?
>> I HAVE APPEALED AND ARTICLES
TO THE NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
LAUNCH AN INVESTIGATION INTO THE
ACTIONS OF JAMES COMEY AND
ANDREW MCCABE.
THESE TWO COLLUDED UNFED OFF
EACH OTHER'S BIASES TO DO A LOT
OF DAMAGE OF THE FBI.
>> Laura: BOTH OF YOU,